he's one of the stars of the suicide
squad which is available in a theater
near you and also exclusively streaming
on hbo max friday august 6th he is back
here on the rich eisen show john cena
how are you john
rich i'm good man good to talk to you
good to be back so these are questions
that i never thought i would ask
somebody
so you get to keep the costume because
you're you're working you're wearing the
peacemaker outfit
and it's technically not mine but i'm
aware
so what are they going to do take it off
of me so as long as i stay in it
i got it so i've okay i haven't changed
my clothes in a while it's been about
a couple years now but at least i still
have a superhero outfit it's true
so you got that going for you and the
gloves too you got the full
on the full-on thing i'm making peace
over here man
i'm just making peace over here you know
what that's just you you only know
one speed i guess and that's
that's to make peace and make that piece
yep
how fun is this for you it looks like
you're having a blast man it's a blast
the movie's fun
promotion is fun uh you know we got a
great group of folks it's like it's
very much like being on a winning team
that has found that groove
and that that clubhouse atmosphere
that's that's where we're at
in this one right and so what did you
enjoy about playing
this role john compared to other ones uh
i could
it's uh it's an r-rated movie so it is
gory and it's a crazy ride all over the
place but it is light-hearted and you
can swing big and you can
you can play fast and loose and uh
obviously
james james gunn has an amazing uh
visionary mind and you know we
like i i once again a sports reference
we got a good team with a great coach
and a bunch of great rapport so we're in
a good spot
so not for the ferdinand crowd my my
daughter shouldn't uh
check this one you know what yet not yet
you just stick it stay a little bit of a
holding pattern and then
you're on yes okay different type of
goring is what you're saying a little
bit yes
a little bit of a different color yeah
okay john cena here on the rich
eisen show did you ever try football in
your life did you ever try and play
man i wasn't any good at it i uh i
played a few years in high school i went
on to play in college
uh i played uh division three for
springfield college
okay and what's your biggest moment of
glory
division three football at springfield
college well i know i know you're very
well versed in the matters of sports so
you know that division three football
isn't real football it's almost like um
four on four i don't know if there's
even barely contact we
we had cardboard uniforms my helmet was
made of lead paint
um i walked up with ways to practice uh
honestly it was a it was literally that
the bonds i made
uh playing i actually still keeping
track or still keep touch with a lot of
my teammates and you know we had some
bad seasons we had some really good
seasons
and i think in that four year journey it
was literally just the camaraderie
developed
so did you what'd you play i played off
the line
yeah fine yeah everybody always asked me
like manny why did you play linebacker
like a fullback or something well you
have to actually be good at football not
to say that offensive linemen aren't
good at football they're very skilled
but i was strong and i could run a
little bit so i
was just the type of athlete that was
like hey go here and hit a guy in a
different colored shirt
and i was okay with that so it's like
the blind okay so
so you were left tackle you were
protecting the center
they let me hit the balls rich i heard
the balls
for a long time i pulled balls and had a
gentleman's hands
in in my in my personal space yes that's
why you're wearing gloves right now
so um so um but senator i mean that's
like
you got to have brains to play that
position like that's not true and i'm
living proof of that
there goes that hypothesis oh my gosh
we ran out we ran like an air force type
uh option or like a navy type triple
option
so offensive lineman were um we were
we pride ourselves on being fast getting
the second level stuff and uh
you know we didn't have to be 300 pounds
and six foot five
so do you have a football team now john
do you root for one team
no i kind of i kind of follow tom brady
because he's kind of following me
okay i'm from new england then he goes
to new england wins a bunch of
championships
then i moved to tampa and he just so
happens to mosey on down to tampa and
now he's trying to get his own thing
started over there
so i follow him just because it's like
we're both stalking each other at least
that's the story
i tell myself yeah i mean this is this
is this is
kind of you know weird but um
it is it's weird i would say it's
completely flattering i mean
the leverages of him peering into my
bedroom window at night they're all
they're all you know they're all high
praise
understood so so he's he you you were in
new england first and then you were in
tampa first
i'm not gonna say that i'm gonna let you
say that okay and now
that's brady's not a bad guy i mean it
is
amazing how many championships that guy
has and how long
you know and it is such a team game you
need a lot of a lot of
things to go right that aren't in your
control to do well
and i just uh i really admire his
dedication to wanting to
to win and to just push himself to the
max and
creating a good team environment and i
think
i can only speculate that he's bestowing
that wisdom upon any team he comes
you know he's a part of which which is
why he's
so sustainable in a league with such a
short lifespan
he really is a bit of an anomaly no
doubt john cena here on the rich
eisenshow again
the suicide squad warner brothers the
suicide squad available in theaters near
you and also
exclusively on hbo max friday august 6th
the reaction you got
when you jumped in the ring with roman
reigns john
was remarkable what was that like to you
when you
you know when the music sting hits and
you hear the reaction and money in the
bank
as you heard in fort worth i'm not used
to that
usually the arena's half of the people
or more are telling me that i suck and
half of the people
are saying let's go cena so i was kind
of expecting that i mean i've been
you know curtailing off my number of
performances for the wwe for the last
few years now because i've been filming
all these projects but i
didn't expect the shift to be that much
and i
i i think that's because it was a
genuine surprise
you know i showed up on the next day on
monday night raw and they they were
still very excited but like
a bunch of chants started some people
were chanting welcome back some people
were chanting let's go cena and some
people were chanting cena sucks but like
they knew i was going to be there so i
think the thing i hold closest about
that money in the bank appearance is in
this day and age
trying to orchestrate some sort of real
genuine surprise is so very rare
and it was it was a genuine moment of
everybody was excited and that led me to
be really excited
yeah how long in advance was that
planned did you
did you you know that's that's level
specific classified information
i will say that it was not planned day
of so
okay so and so um summerslam is
definitely in the cards for you to see
one more time that's going to happen
uh that's not up to me that's up to the
wwe universal champion roman reigns i
went on monday night raw and issued a
challenge
and kind of said like hey i'm here for
this
but i can't just jump to the front of
the line without the guy
who holds the championship saying it's
okay so friday on smackdown
he's more than likely going to have some
splaining to do or some some things he'd
like to say and we'll go from there
so this is pretty cool for you john
obviously you know
um you're you're in some tentpole movies
and then you're also doing what you're
doing um
with the wwe and seeing the reaction i
mean what are
what are your thoughts now that you're
you're at this point for your career and
and and able to sort of straddle both
lines here
it's exciting i mean even at my age i'm
walking around with a tent pole all the
time
it's very exciting i you know as soon as
i said that word
i thought to myself i've kind of opened
my flank a little bit
just making peace over here
it's uh you know it's it's great man it
really is to and and
honestly i'm at a a stage
in in my life both professionally and
personally where
i'm enjoying everything and and i i
guess i'm more present and i'm more
uh here and and i really do enjoy the
whole process
and i think when you're trying to
establish yourself when you're trying to
get that mojo going when you're trying
to start a winning streak or trying to
get a snowball
rolling downhill you're always focused
on what's next you're
you're really hyper sensitive about like
i don't want to derail the
the efforts and something's good now i'm
just kind of
rolling with it man and it's really
really fun i get to
i do i get to really take chances and
and some hit and some don't and
you know sometimes i put my foot in my
mouth and sometimes i move on and then
like it's it really is just fun well
congrats on it man uh the suicide squad
in theaters nationwide and streaming
exclusively on hbo max friday august 6th
you keep making peace john we need you
on that wall yeah always a pleasure man
right back at you that's john cena right
here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here